hello from comic-con this annual event
is a mecca for science fiction and comic
book fans and everyone who knows Stanley
from Jim Lee should make the pilgrimage
here it's also a place where you can let
your geek flag fly and cosplay as your
favorite character without fear of
getting a wedgie from bullies but you'll
notice that I've left my Chewbacca
bodysuit at home it's not because I
don't want to send the wrong signal to
furries although I don't it's because
I'm incensed by the restrictive policies
on costume weaponry at comic-con just
take a look at the guidelines on
comic-con internationals website this
fascist document asserts that all swords
guns laser pistols glaives phasers
bat'leth etc must be inspected at the
weapons check desk all projectile
weapons must be rendered inoperable it's
like my Boba Fett action figure all over
again costume swords they have to be
tied down so they can't be drawn madness
what is this some evil sith plot all
weapons must be tagged and every
cosplayer must wear a wristband
designating that they have passed this
stringent check look nothing destroys
the effect of a conan the barbarian
costume more than safety tags and
wristbands well except for a pale in
flatty physique but the tags and
wristbands run a close second look
superheroes like Phoenix and Blue Beetle
fought and died for my right to bear
imaginary costume weaponry you've heard
of the Tea Party we need to start a
costume ball don't tread on me comic-con
international
subscribe to the wire channel and let me
know in the comments what really grinds
your gears about cosplay restrictions